[Music]
welcome back so in the last lecture I
showed you how to solve the heat
equation using the fast Fourier
transform and in this lecture I'm going
to show you how to solve the one-way
wave equation and burgers equation okay
so a linear wave equation and a
nonlinear wave equation
so the first one we're gonna solve is is
U T plus C UX equals zero at least I
think that's the one I'm solving let's
double check okay good that's one I'm
solving so basically if I have some wave
some initial condition u this wave is
just going to travel from left to right
with some constant speed C that's that's
just the linear wave equation and what
we're going to do is just like before
we're gonna Fourier transform this u
variable with respect to X and we're
gonna solve this in terms of U hat this
function of a spatial wave number K and
time T okay and so we're gonna use this
relationship here that says that u X
when I Fourier transform becomes I times
Kappa times u hat so if I Fourier
transform this I get u hat time
derivative equals minus C times I times
Kappa times u happen okay maybe I could
have put my I outside it doesn't matter
it's you know minus I times C times
Kappa times u hat this is the right-hand
side for my OTE integrator and I'm just
gonna solve this I'm gonna solve this
system of ordinary differential
equations using OD 45 in MATLAB okay so
really simple just like before I'm gonna
define a domain this time my length of
the domain is 20 from minus 10 to 10 I'm
defining my kappa variables I'm gonna
define an initial condition which is a
hyperbolic secant this is basically just
a Gaussian function in X and u hat
naught is the Fourier transform of that
initial condition happens to also be a
Gaussian Fourier transform of the
Gaussian is always a Gaussian okay and
then all the the kind of real
computation is happening here where we
actually run OD 45 on this particular
vector field so
the right-hand-side wave we're gonna
lock in kappa and see the the vector of
frequencies and the the wave speed c and
we're gonna make this just a function of
time and the state vector u hat that
we're integrating and then we're gonna
integrate through a time vector t
starting from initial condition you have
not okay and just like before we have to
define this right-hand side so this
function d u hat dt just the time
derivative of my knife fourier transform
variable u hat and it's super simple
it's just minus C times I times Kappa
times u hat and again because Kappa is a
vector of frequencies I have to take
Kappa dot times u hat to get Kappa 1 u
hat 1 kappa 2 u had to and so on and so
forth okay so that's my right hand side
vector really simple we're just going to
always work in the Fourier domain we're
working in U hat space and then once
we've solved this PDE we're gonna
inverse Fourier transform and recover
our function U as a function of space
and time okay so let's run this pretty
simple
okay it runs really fast and now I'm
gonna plot it just like before I'm gonna
plot a waterfall plot ooh do that not
like okay it did not like my let me just
run this again oh this is always
dangerous to code live what did I change
error patch it doesn't like this being
complex okay good so I'm going to
remember when u inverse for you
transform this function it should be
real valued like I can't have a wave I
can't have this real valued PDE give
imaginary solutions but when I inverse
for you transform I might get machine
precision complex numbers and so what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
make this a real I'm gonna take the real
part of U it should be like almost
entirely real but I'm gonna kill all of
those tiny tiny complex parts hopefully
that fixes everything
ah perfect okay so now this is what my
wave equation looks like in a waterfall
plot and I'm just gonna rotate this so
it's a little bit easier to see in space
and time
so you can see my original kind of
Gaussian in as time evolves this just
moves from left to right at a constant
speed
there's no deformation and there's no
diffusion nothing is happening except
this wave is being carried from left to
right with no deformation that's the
linear one-way wave equation that's what
this PDE does and you see that our FFT
solution is exactly capturing that that
basic behavior so that's really good to
see okay there's another way of plotting
this in a movie which i think is kind of
nice so you can see this thing moving
from left to right I'll just play that
one more time for you moving from left
to right okay good it's so simple I can
basically sell my PDE by mapping into
the into the Fourier domain taking the
Fourier transform in space simulating
this Fourier transformed variable
equation forward in time using OD 45
it's easy because now I don't have to
approximate these derivatives with like
a finite difference scheme or something
awful like that I can just use this nice
spectral derivative which is very
accurate and then when I'm done I can
always inverse Fourier transform and
recover my system okay so that's quite
nice you'll notice this line 24 and 23
says alternatively we can simulate in
the spatial domain technically
technically I don't actually have to
Fourier transform this and solve my uhat
forward in time I could technically
solve this equation u T equals minus C u
X in space and in time but then I'd have
to approximate this derivative and I
could of course do that with a finite
difference central difference or some
you know some stenciled find that
difference derivative but that would be
an accurate and expensive in just a pain
so instead what I'm gonna do in this
right-hand wave spatial this is the
right-hand side if I solve my OD e up
here so in the first example I solved my
OD e down here that's the first example
in the
second example I'm going to show how to
solve my OD e up here without Fourier
transforming but the trick is to
approximate you X I'm going to take my
my variable U I'm gonna Fourier
transform I'm going to compute the
derivative in the Fourier transform
domain using this and then I'm gonna
inverse Fourier transform to get my
derivative u X so I'm still gonna use my
my Fourier transform to approximate this
derivative but then I'm just gonna
simulate this OD e I'm just gonna say
that the state of my system is U of X
and I'm gonna simulate this OD forward
but using the FFT to compute this
derivative okay so that's also totally
fine the reason I'm showing you this is
because this is how we're gonna solve
the burgers equation which is non linear
where we can't solve it all in the 48
domain okay so I'm gonna go back now
we're solving this wave equation using
this line 24 we're simulating in space
and if I did everything right nothing
should change okay same exact same exact
behavior of the wave equation okay so
technically I can solve it in frequency
domain or in space but I can use to some
extent it's more efficient to do it to
simulate it in here because I only
Fourier transform in once then I solved
this with OD 45 and then I only take an
inverse Fourier transform when I want to
come back to real space whereas when I
solve it up here I'm constantly Fourier
transforming and inverse Fourier
transforming every time step to compute
this derivative so that's a little bit
more cumbersome but you can do it okay
and so in the last example I'm going to
show you how to solve the burgers
equation which is a nonlinear a
nonlinear PDE so maybe I'll change
colors this is UT plus u times UX equals
nu times u xx so this is burgers
equation well known to be the most
delicious of all one dimensional PDE s
and what I'm gonna do first of all is
we're going to just kind of ignore this
diffusion term and if you just had UT
plus U you
x equals zero it would look a lot like
this wave equation except the wave speed
would be proportional to the amplitude
of the wave so if I have if I start with
that Gaussian here the higher the point
the faster it's moving to the right and
so everything is going to move to the
right but the higher points are going to
move to the right faster than the slower
points and so they're gonna stack up on
top of the slower points and eventually
they're gonna form these sharp shock
waves
okay so burgers equation is a nice model
of how shocks form in in fluid systems
for example like real shock waves where
you get this kind of infinite sharp
infinitely sharp wave front because the
wave speed is proportional to the
amplitude and so these higher points
over take the slower points okay and
this is numerically unstable to simulate
unless you add this diffusion term this
is called a regularizer this this is a
regularizing diffusion regularizing
diffusion and so what that does we know
that this heat equation the diffusion
operator hates high frequency Fourier
modes it hates high frequency stuff and
it tries to kill or diffuse those high
frequencies out and so when this shock
starts to form if I had this diffusion
here if it becomes too steep this term
kicks on and it kind of balances it out
so this diffusion term fights this
nonlinear convection and so what we get
is you still get this kind of formation
of shocks but they don't become
infinitely steep they only become kind
of this finite shock with here
that's balancing the diffusion and in
the convection okay so a really fun kind
of useful nonlinear one dimensional PDE
we're gonna solve it the exact same way
using the FFT except now I can't work
only in the spatial domain or only in
the Fourier domain I can't pick one and
only work in those domains because for
example this product if I Fourier
transform is going to get really nasty
it's gonna be some kind of nasty
convolution so what I'm gonna do is
like in my second example I'm going to
solve this PDE in the spatial domain I'm
gonna solve this PDE this is gonna be my
state vector U and I'm gonna time step
it using ode45
but I'm going to approximate all of
these derivatives by taking the fast
Fourier transform okay so that's what
we're doing here in this right hand side
burgers just walk us through this is my
pseudo code for the PDE right here okay
so what do we do we take U and we
Fourier transform it to get U hat then
we compute the first and second
derivative D u hat and D D u hat the
first and second derivatives and then I
inverse fast Fourier transform those two
get in space u X and u xx and now I can
build this right hand side minus u times
u X plus nu times u xx ok pretty simple
I'm just using the fast Fourier
transform to approximate the derivatives
but I'm actually writing down you know
this right hand side in real spatial
units so I I for you transform in I
compute my derivatives and I Fourier
transform out to build this right hand
side so again not super efficient right
I'm doing two Fourier transforms every
time step but it's very very accurate
weight of approximating these
derivatives it's like the most accurate
you can get to approximate these
derivatives is to be doing this in the
Fourier domain and so just like all of
the examples I have some spatial domains
some Kappa frequencies some initial
condition and we owed EE 45 this burgers
equation okay so I'm gonna run all of
that right now
good and I'm gonna plot this as a
waterfall so I think this looks really
neat you can see this shock steepening
okay so you can see that you started
with that Gaussian but very very rapidly
what happens is this front starts to
form and it starts to steep and up but
it can't get too steep because of this
this this linear diffusion this
regularizing diffusion can't let it get
too steep because if it got too steep
these high frequencies would get would
decay faster than they can form that's
that that's this balance this formation
of shocks and this is dissipating my
shocks
okay and similarly we can plot this
movie in time this looks pretty cool to
see that shock forming I'll play that
one more time for you okay so you can
see this shock forming in time okay good
so I hope that what I've convinced you
of is that you can solve PDE s
efficiently using the fast Fourier
transform and there's a few ways you can
do it if you're lucky like in the heat
equation or in this one-way wave
equation you can map directly into the
Fourier domain and you can solve
everything in the Fourier domain because
it's linear essentially because your PDE
is linear you can simulate this in the
Fourier domain your derivatives become
essentially multiplications by a Kappa
vector okay or a cap a squared vector
and then when you're done you inverse
Fourier transform to get back to your
real spatial solution you can also use
this for nonlinear PDEs like the burgers
equation but in this case you're only
using the FFT to approximate these
derivatives okay so you kind of take
your state you map into the Fourier
domain you compute your derivatives and
then you map back into the real spatial
domain where you can build this right
hand side a viewer of your system so in
all of these cases what you're doing is
you're taking your system state U which
is a big vector for every instant in
time this is a vector of U at all of
your spatial locations and you're
stepping that forward in time using OD
e45 or you're taking your vector of
fourier coefficients also at every
instant in time and you're stepping that
forward with o de 45 so that's basically
what you're doing is you're treating
your your PDE state U as a discrete
state vector with n elements either in
space or in frequency components and
we're integrating those forward in time
using ode45
you know essentially integrating these
forward in time and you could use
different OD integrators you could use
forward Euler an implicit scheme some
higher-order OTE you can use you know
any time step or you like essentially to
walk this state forward in time
depending on what accuracy and kind of
what other properties you want for your
system okay
but the real headline here is that you
can use the Fourier transform to
efficiently map into a space where you
can compute these derivatives very very
accurately and efficiently okay yeah so
I encourage you to use this if I were
you what I would do is try to solve
maybe the Navy or Stokes equations on a
periodic domain this should be one line
one line and two lines okay so what you
can do is you can try to solve the Navy
or Stokes equations on a two-dimensional
grid where you Fourier transform an X
and an Y then you solve that big system
of equations for word and time and you
you inverse Fourier transform so that
would be my recommendation for you if
you want to practice this and try it out
okay thank you